ich weiß nicht wie es geht wir sehen
solche bilder sehen ganz oft und denken
das kann bei uns nicht passieren
jetzt ist auch in trier passiert ich
kann die motivation es gilt als nicht
aber sämtliche rettungskräfte der
berufsfeuerwehr rettungsdienst nicht
alles kreieren sondern aus der gesamten
region sind unterwegs und ohne dass er
im moment die zahlen bestätigen können
alle sind damit beschäftigt verletzte
und schwerstverletzte im moment in die
krankenhäuser zu bringen und ich drücke
allen ganz arg die daumen dass die
schwersten verletzten auch überleben
ich bin kann durch gegenstand gelaufen
und es war einfach befremdlich
vor
das wären dann zum tod
das vielen weiteren zahlen
dank ihrer betriebe und ganz beim spiel
und spaß
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren